management no cuts takemoto Emma's
shadow cabinet member I'm dealing with
the National Service in ldp of the
Japanese government I think it is a most
important to read in the hydrogen Europe
Asia now in such kind of crisis that you
combine so many various countries in 17
countries circle so for example Joey and
transit will be country doctor quickly
the priest baseman country but they are
doing the same thing so they're going to
provide quite different double-click is
a solemn moment gender quest to to us
Japanese people you know hydration which
happened in the am also sure asprova
class so pizza Europe should become a
much more powerful and our two countries
in intervening over Ekans